hey everybody what is up in a Mac here
for animal roar welcome to another
episode of rant cafe
number 55 zero guys five zero pretty
insane that's almost a year of rant
cafes if not already i years were
somewhere around the year mark
crazy are happy to have everyone here
again this week we're going to be
discussing the big controversial
interesting topic that was launched by a
video by ScrewAttack comparing ichigo
and naruto the death battle between
ichigo and naruto who is the stronger
anime character obviously two iconic
shounen jump characters right there a
lot of controversy was generated knocks
you said this video just came out like
yesterday or two days ago or something
yeah yeah so it's gonna be it's gonna be
an interesting time we're gonna be
talking about that specific video in
battle and we're gonna be talked about
in general does it make sense to take
characters from different worlds
different anime and try to compare them
is it possible is it just impossible to
do all that kind of stuff it's gonna be
fun
joining me we have the aforementioned
NOx taka what's up bro
nothing much good to be here happy to
talk about anime that all four of us
have watched yes yeah good tell you back
NOx we also have anime recon in the
house he was absent last week because
he's a [ __ ] what's up enemy recon
what is up sorry I'm almost absent just
at university we're caught me as I'm a
life outside of sword art online and
[ __ ] no [ __ ] of course way no complain
in you too I act like I love Sao but
outside I act like a normal human being
it's not normal to like Sao that's going
you can ask a soul yourself that is a
very good way to put it and I respect
that and lastly we also have our boys
soul maka in the house what's up soul
you know everyone how you doing good to
be back man good to be back yeah like
last week you were working but you know
being a busy man but now you're back to
rant about anime
gonna be good and yes personally well I
saw a Fitz
of Naruto and bleach I had never
actually got into either of those series
the only shown and long-running showing
that I'm caught up with is actually
Dragonball so there you go but I know
Knox and soul maka are big on bleach and
Naruto I'm pretty sure soul doctor has
had like a tower voice chat debates
about both shows so it's gonna be fun to
do this also we're going to have an
after-party in the voice chat of our
discord server after this rank of face
so if you want to look in the
description that's you can join us there
after the stream and yeah who wants to
start us up knocks you wanted to do this
topic you were excited to do it so I
don't know start off what did you like
about the video what are some of the
things you want to discuss solo to you
my friend and by the way NOx is a big
Naruto slash board to a youtuber now so
you know yeah yeah I uploaded like three
boruto videos I'm a big boruto youtuber
well no one else no one else uploads
three de bordo videos
I wouldn't even isn't much to say on the
subject but um as far as the death
battle I've been following screw a tank
for a little while like back since you
know the Goku vs. Superman days and I
think this was a good one you know
usually I disagree with like half of
what they say but quite frankly this was
a good one they basically labeled their
powers pretty accurately and even though
faster-than-light can't really be
fathomable and saying oh he's faster
than light because he dodged an attack
that was said by legend to be as fast as
lightning and while that's probably not
actually fact that it was fast as
lightning you know it was a pretty
accurate portrayal of powers and I think
the outcome was fairly you know made
sense which is scary yeah well I think
definitely definitely there's a lot of
research done in this video like
obviously again it's very hard to
compare two different animes so you can
debate a lot of it which is what we're
gonna be doing but I I would absolutely
agree with you NOx that there was a lot
of research that went into it there was
a lot of you know trying to do powers
scaling as much as possible the
different techniques stuff like that so
I definitely respect the effort I as a
youtuber you know how much work it would
take to make a video like that so for
sure respect to that soul well talking
about research I think not enough was
done on the bleach side right the bleach
basically they had up until the Eisen
fight when he had the full gets
attention I would agree
they didn't cover the full bring and it
that breaker he lost didn't he landfill
ring and they definitely still have it
but he never used it because it's way
weaker than everything else he has but
it still added to his power you have to
let soul finish he let you finish but
what if he's wrong
no but they correct him at the end knows
they still didn't town he's true power
as well with his Quincy power and stuff
that was feature that at the end the
last arc of the manga even though with
Naruto they were showing all his power
all the way up until the end of the
story so it was still like imbalance it
was still in favor of Naruto
well to be fair first of all before I
watched it I said to anime well Naruto
is gonna win just because it's more
popular and they don't want to do
another Dragon Ball vs. Superman thing
and yeah but as far as um measuring his
power all the powers ichigo really had
were getsuga tensho and at the end yet
is mega Seto thing that was basically
everything he could do while all of his
other powers were augmenting how Harvey
said augmentation abilities where he
started off as had with shikai bankai
what did I do it just made him faster
and stronger hollow form that just made
him faster and stronger berserk hollow
whatever it's called Vasto Lorde is
formed that just made him you know
stronger and faster and so on that was
basically what his power boosts were no
but his Quincy Power also gave him a
defensive power right he had that blunt
blunt vein thing so if something was in
contact with him if it could
enjoy him then it would all
automatically kick in like an explosive
force field in a sense and it would it
would no yeah hold that up for because
one rasen shuriken of Naruto's from like
back in the day when he fought pain you
know what attacked the person at the
molecular level for like minutes oh yeah
no no yeah yeah I know like the percent
shuriken thing oh that was not even
comparing to is bijuu dama in his sage
form you know ninetails cloak chakra
mode from the six paths alien guy yeah
right away lord artorias in the chat
says he's asking anti Mac what death
battle would you make and that's an
interesting question we'll talk about
that after we talk about this specific
one because I definitely want to talk
about in general the concept of death
battles and some other ones that would
be interesting but just watching the
video and looking at all day you know
their tanks talking about how Naruto's
power and ichigo's power is advancing no
one could say [ __ ] about Dragon Ball
anymore man because all of these
protagonists are illogically Opie just
powers up on top of powers like so it's
all the same in these long-running
shonan's so people who choose this
Dragon Ball because they're like oh man
you just keep getting new forms so Lu
these guys so like like Naruto has some
kind of alien / frickin nine tailed fox
slash all these different things just
like stuck and one on top of the other
like come on right so in Naruto and well
not bleach really but in Naruto's
defense everyone said that after the
pain arc Naruto got worse and until the
pain arc he really didn't have these
stackable abilities it was only in like
the last the final battle was where he
literally developed chakra mode sage
chakra mode yin-yang bullcrap saved six
paths of whatever it's called sage of
six paths Jesus mode Jesus he developed
all of his Jesus powers in literally the
last arc in the last battle until that
point he sucked I mean use that you
getting better you know comparatively to
the rest of the cat the characters or
whatever but you know he didn't it
wasn't just oh new form time yeah yeah
so that's I like I like across he said
in the chat what plot no armor no jutsu
very good point
oh yeah that's interesting so you're
saying that in the last arc they got not
all these different powers as if they
wanted to hedge their bets for a
potential death battle in the future
they're like look we're in the last
battle let's just give him all these
powers so then when people do him in a
death battle they gotta make him this
strong they just made the bad guy so
crazy Opie and then they had that bad
guy be beaten by the queen of bad guys
they had to somehow a give Naruto some
sort of chance they had to make him get
these creepy little black ball of Doom's
that whoever touches the little black
floaty thingy is annihilated and it
could block any attack without him even
noticing and not only can he sense you
know chakra at this point he can sense
emotions from any distances he can fight
clones that are in a different plane of
existence you know they come up with
cool stuff in the last arc of Naruto
alright enough of you guys now it's time
for the recon step in what do you want
to go Nazis the bastion I'm watching the
video it was good I like the whole idea
of the concept but I haven't watched
Naruto or bleach I haven't even got to
them because they're too long for me
good
oh no the only long one we saw and I've
watched was Fairy Tail and that's it so
from watching this video I like the idea
of him you know saying all the moves and
all the power-ups that they've got and
he was making he was like like taking a
piss a little bit and I went through the
comment section down in the video and
there were like huge debates on which
show is better who will win all stuff
but for me I would say Naruto and Ichigo
however you pronounce his [ __ ] name
they can go [ __ ] themselves
because if Natsu was there he would
annihilate them both and the story boom
Nandi wouldn't second I'm pretty sure
you would
second of all what something Kirito
wouldn't either
yo Kirito what and I like them all even
Natsu yeah that's just that's just my
opinion everybody has different opinions
don't worry this is death battle if it's
supposed to not be any opinions it's
just Frank it's like I'll give you an
example I think if all might would fight
Ichigo
it would be a pretty close fight oh my
all might cause if they both have
approximately light speed movements and
yet incredible strength and I think in
the end
Ichigo would win but that would be a
closer fight just comparing their
strengths I don't know about the one
thing I like about not to like
especially the last in the last episode
of Fairy Tail he shows up again he walks
into this massive arena and the whole
arena just melts yeah pretty pretty
badass
but compare that to you know I call a
buzz about Scholl and bleach ego
compare that to ichigo's cero thing that
can wipe out like half the United States
in one shot that's not so impressive
yeah like I would say now is definitely
a cool character in terms of just not
like you know being a badass but in
terms of power he can compare to Naruto
Ichigo anyone from like dragon ball like
it's just that's just common sense
also recon no one can blame you knowing
you we're not watching Naruto and bleach
fun watching fairy tale because there is
not there are not enough boobs in Naruto
and bleach exactly anime exactly why
would I watch them they don't they don't
have the necessary fanservice that I
need however very Taylor has other stuff
in bleachers here like the first 50
episodes over so of bleach that has
enough oppai for recon and arrow 81 the
one not only can stole society the great
ichigo yoruichi
I don't know her name but like she's
like a fighter and she has like massive
boobs and she has like a brother
you're literally say mentioning every
character in Bleach right now are you
are you talking about Matsumoto the girl
with the huge rack that like drowns
people in her boobs
well she trains ichigo there in a sauce
we're talking about the dark skin oh
yeah she's talking about yuuichi in it
that dark skin yeah the one that's turns
into the girl that shows up at every
like two episodes what she's the only
one who's trained Ichigo nah the females
train did she go as she sure whatever
the point is yes there is some boobs but
you have to wait for it at least a few
arcs or like an arc and a half whereas
you know in fairytale you're just like
Lucy airs ah let's do it that's what my
boy Rika wants and I understand that
exactly
I know vak feels the same way but I
don't mind at all to my surprise is um
he has the ability to stop time like a
battle and they would like jump at each
other and be like an inch away from each
other and then they would have like the
whole conversation you know it's like
Dragon Ball super like the tournaments
how long like 10 minutes yeah and it's
like [ __ ] yeah the tournament is like 40
episodes and it's supposed to be like 40
minutes long well I actually did a
calculation I'm doing an honest
descriptions on the war arc of Naruto
right now so I did a calculation
Naruto is on screen for more than 48
hours and the war is less than two days
long explain that
and it's day four that whole time in
Dragon Ball super the tournament arc
they a whole episode which is over 20
minutes would pass and
they would say that one minute has
passed in the tournament at the end of
the episode you got a love dragon ball
that's the whole point oldest shonan's
are like that that's just like you
haven't seen any of actually good
shonan's though like your opinion no no
I mean like Frank Hunter hunter is
better than dragon ball one piece Naruto
or whatever dr. hunter is not even that
long compared to the other hunters 150
episodes and it's amazing and it makes a
lot of sense throughout and the power
levels do as well
we will never finish but it will likely
never finish the enemy as the Dragon
Ball super has to be slowed down so that
humans can actually follow what's going
on otherwise they're like all over the
place really high-pitched really since
since we have a new shown in a
long-running shauna anime called black
clover would you think what do you think
Aastha would win against Naruto no right
now yes good moment do you think us that
can't win against Naruto can I just say
my favorite moment from the last episode
of black clover oh yeah bloating
fireball thingy he throws it at asta and
asked her and the show pauses and the
narrator's like pasta didn't know how he
would survive this attack he even knew
that if you would swing his sword at the
attack it would do nothing but Oscars
body instinctively decides to turn the
sword sideways deflecting the attack now
like three minutes of narration in this
really stupid pathetic move and everyone
saw coming basically black clover hasta
has ultra instinct is what you're saying
no I was gonna say I was gonna say it's
like that meme in it you know where you
see like someone about to do something
and then it pauses and it goes in that
moment he knew
no but the thing is the thing is guys
that I don't you can't even compare
black clover to naruto bleach black
clover is even the manga is shorter than
my hero academia and my hero academia
has nothing compared to how long bleach
and our job been going on so that's not
even a contest by the way who's uma ki
Naruto in the comments says the subject
is death battle guys I guess he just
wants to talk about how he won yeah I
guess so talk about how great Naruto an
ANBU in the Chad Nick victory fire Lum
King a bunch of the regular peeps are
here Gore the Jack you're talking about
Superman owning Goku that's just
nonsense does respond sense Superman
have you seen the death battles of
Superman versus Goku those those I think
were fair I mean Goku would get be I
mean yeah Green is so overpowered is the
only character from Dragonball that
would annihilate Superman is Crillon it
stated that his Destructo disc can cut
through anything according to our I
don't mean to be rude or anything
Superman is technically considered
anything and therefore can be cut in
half by super destructor this thingy no
no but the only problem is over no but
the only problem is that the struck toad
this has to be able to hit Superman
first Superman chill or any would have
let it hit him weaknesses [ __ ]
kryptonite do guys I don't even want to
hear it because Superman couldn't even
beat Batman decisively in the [ __ ]
movie so don't tell me it's Superman can
beat Goku like get out of it I'm pretty
hear that Batman would be Goku yeah how
about this Batman can't flying Goku can
fly who wins
of course Goku in because he can fly he
can evade any attack it's great that
you're coming with this logic but
Superman can all
why well Superman shouldn't be able to
fly the original Superman couldn't fly
just jump very high and then they just
kept giving him power where they fly but
no no it's technically a really good job
yeah well technically they kept adding
more power on super in the original
couldn't even fly but they kept acting
more adding more power making more hopi
by the way soul madness on the Goku
unlike Goku is not getting any more Opie
right oh yeah I grew up with the best
but slow madness weaker in the chat says
that she'll be fair bleach verse overall
is more powerful than Naruto verse what
do you say to that
hundred percent accurate Naruto well
another thing about ichigo that he has
is um Quincy's have a weakness to hollow
to soul reaper powers and hollows have a
weakness to Quincy powers and Soul
Reapers have a weakness to hollow powers
Ichigo has all of three all three of
these and therefore no matter who he's
fighting he's super effective on them
and that gives him another edge where
that doesn't help him against Naruto at
all what ya know two worlds colliding
what I think it's colliding now your
average ninja doesn't stand a chance
against your ever well yeah I mean I'd
say instinctively I'd say the speed
feats are more faster in leash naturally
if you like using like the space-time
jutsus then you know that might match it
but new or doesn't have that so well or
if you're including as far as the Naruto
verse there are many like way
overpowered hacks jutsus that are not
overused like for example both comely
and Amata to zu are two unblockable
techniques that move at the speed of
light
whatever he looks at either gets warped
into another dimension or lights on a
black flame that's indistinct
inextinguishable yeah and until it
consumes everything it's on so both of
these techniques would beat anyone from
any
show almost ever like no one can lie
faster than light and they can juicers
and again the engine is you point at the
guy and he's incapacitated it touch you
would I owned them all
that's all I feel like some of those
logia users from one piece could [ __ ]
these guys up man
well one thing about okay so hockey can
defeat the low gear lose users from one
piece and why is that any different than
you know spiritual pressure or chakra
because bra like like pika-pika know me
and like the Lightning one and the white
one so the electricity and light logia
fruits I feel would be pretty fun
because you can they can both speed of
movement the speed of light right so
again in the one-piece universe itself I
don't see how they were beaten no matter
how powerful you are light is freakin
fast and according to death panels
calculations and what they've said in
different fan books and whatever Naruto
and Ichigo both move out light speed as
well who's that cute little kid her name
is Minnie maka yeah like that to me I
don't like the concept of oh just all
the all the shorter protagonist end up
moving like to be the speed of light
like impossible speeds and Dragonball
you got Instant Transmission like all
this [ __ ] it kind of like it just goes
so Opie that it's like what the [ __ ]
like where do they go from here that's
the power ceiling that's necessary and
just say my opinion that putting two
different characters completely from two
different worlds isn't really that fair
what's what is fair mean what exactly
make things bounce like take two
characters from the same show and then
you know different what's the fun what's
the fun in that the point of this is to
make it more interesting who would win
this guy I don't know
I know it's make it more interesting but
too many people including me it could
not be fair it's not balanced what is
fair what does fear me o my father what
is love
listen um so we have sarcastic panda
saying that counsel from quano Suba is
the best protagonist ever I think
completely random comment however no
because Kazuma isn't getting it on with
aqua and darkness and he totally could
be but he isn't how do you why he's not
the Betty now how do you know he's not
because they specifically had the scene
with like darkness in the shower and
they didn't end up doing it and they're
all girls and it's like bro it's like
bro you think if communist was in a
mansion with three chicks he wouldn't be
doing them come on wait wait wait wait
no no way but did did come and I
actually do he's go I think he knew her
for a day bro point is the point is were
staying a crappy guy the point
the thing is cosmo needs to be a man and
smash smash okay smash back on topic so
did you say whether or not you agree
with the outcome oh oh no no no I
thought it's very one-sided the outcome
of the screwattack video is it was too
one-sided for me I thought it absolutely
took the piss when it had Ichigo use
these a final getsugatensho and then
after I ended up like powerless and then
just picking up a fork in a stick yeah I
mean while I still got like full power
and it just goes all-out attack on him
yeah I'm for that
that just absolutely took the piss I
love how they finished their fights off
in the Pokemon vs Digimon fight in the
end they had like Charizard land on red
and break his legs and then they just
nuke the two of them like that's how you
kill a character no we're not gonna
half-ass
they're gonna annihilate him you can
yeah let him take the piss dole so your
point is that you thought it was
one-sided stacked for Naruto you think
Ichigo actually you think personally if
you were doing it with Ichigo two one
no no I when I said that Ichigo would
have won exactly because like he's final
his final form in the manga we didn't
really get to see much of its
capabilities but he would have had some
abilities to making himself at least
look more decent you know would he
actually have one I don't know it's
really hard to say because like we we
literally have one attack of his actual
proper like final form within the story
that that's not enough to really do
anything defensive capabilities not
really that good considering who he was
fighting and the guy just kind of
basically just like beat him with a
finger yeah so it's kind of terrible to
try and judge oh oh you're a master at
pronouncing the names of characters or
hannah me right so I can you please
pronounce the king of the Quincy's name
for me you how about your you know doc
that [ __ ] that's you should actually
know you should know the pronunciation
should I knew Harbach yes doesn't it
come from like Yiddish German its German
and it's like German see stuff is German
all the hollow stuff is like Spanish
although Yiddish is based up German so
so yeah okay so we had an interesting
comment by demonic skull he says Naruto
should have one but it was dumb how it
you go lost so that's another thing too
it's like when you're making these types
of videos you have to be so
detail-oriented and it's almost
impossible to get everything right and
you know like it Scott
horse yes just yeah it's just you know
that's how I'm saying sorry it took the
piss how he lost like he shouldn't
unlost in that in that way you know
being absolutely powerless and just
holding a bloody twig and he's like come
at me bro yeah I mean they had to kill
him how are you gonna kill him after
uses its ultra mood thingy he goes no
you know no but you should at least like
give him powers so that feels like you
know they do one big final clash and
then after you know when the dust clears
you seen a root on top or something you
know that would have made it feel more
like alright okay rather than you know
he's left powerless he's just in these
plain clothes he's got this stick and
his massive attack comes in and he just
they're like I hate you and they just
gets taken out that's yeah I don't like
cream at the end I thought that was
already just saying sorry bleep it you
know you suck knocks why don't you make
a video on a death battle maybe I can't
and maybe you come on whatever job
yeah well that is an interesting
question what death battles would we do
we can get back that in a little bit
once we finish this whole guy yeah do
some sick what's that phenol we would
make and how we're gonna get an hour of
knocks with his eighteen editors to make
that happen
the only have seven editors and I love
all of you if any you're watching
start Dannic Dannic pani yet up did
naruto is smart god well naruto is part
everything and so is Ichigo Ichie goes
part they're all part everything you
guys right so there was another point
that I wanted to mention if Ichigo would
have really been in the Naruto universe
he would have also been an Uchiha and
Hyuga and a who well Ichigo oh yeah he
was cool enough to be a few mistletoe B
he would have been he was a human soul
reaper Hollow Quincy full bringer
super saiyan mega level digimon mega
absolutely anyway guys if you enjoy rank
of a don't forget to leave a like I know
a lot of people forget to leave a like
and then they're like yo man I forgot to
leave a like but you've already got 4
dislikes yeah well duh that's the that's
the people who thought that Luffy
should've won Luffy would be a better
fight against Natsu and he would
demolish Natsu know that not soon I
don't know about that you know no no no
he's rubber yeah Fire Opal known to
rubber exactly mounts he's literally a
rubber man he's made of rubber okay okay
how about you you guys choose between
these two would you be a Hokage or would
you want to be a wizard King choose oh
[ __ ] off like a pain in the ass a lot of
paperwork I'll tell you one thing though
Astor with these powers could actually
beat Natsu no yes because rigor econ
edition he has a sort that can cancel
magic it can nullify magic magic and he
beat dragon fire it's magic if it's
magic
then yeah I don't think dragon fire is
magic it's just magic you douche they're
wizards in Fairy Tail
Oh magic games it's okay we can we still
love these yeah it's funny because recon
is asking us would you rather be Hokage
or the wizard King and I'm just thinking
I'd rather be the harem King bro yeah
I'm asking you to I wouldn't be both I'm
they are more even harem King I was
right I was rather be like Cosmo but not
a [ __ ] when it comes to getting the
chicks that any of these like
ninjas and [ __ ] I don't know I think
ninjas and pretty cool to be quite
honest it's pretty cool you can't get
your [ __ ] if you could fire off for a
say guns so that's why you would want to
be Hokage to get [ __ ] knock some to
see it is an added bonus for sure as as
a lower two youtubers shame on you bro
shut the hell up man I am NOT stooping
to that level I am NOT a shounen
youtuber you pretty much are because all
you upload is shown in anime yeah is
that true yeah oh yeah very minimal from
a bunch of other shows but mostly you
focus on shown in anime which I don't
mind it's cool yeah and then this whole
thing about what is shown in right so
let's not get into that because some
people say attack on Titan is shown in
and there's definitely not a traditional
Ronin but like so yeah let's not get
into that you see like you know you have
to see the difference between like the
bat was shown in and yeah I mean because
that's what like you know nooooo bleach
took in one period all kind of thing
berry d.gray-man you know all that is
that battle shana yes because they're so
long-running in these types of battle
shown and they need to keep it
interesting so they need to keep getting
new powers and stacked powers and this
in part needs to evolve in it was he sub
I mean the problem is though we like
Dragon Ball Dragon Boat that that
ceiling he's like I don't know where
it's gone you don't exactly know it's
just all the way it's gone my hero in my
hero academia though they do have a
power ceiling and that's why it works
because you know he's not that much more
powerful than all mine and all might was
seen fight at the end of the first
season he won't transcend that by that
much so there is a range at least in my
here well while in in the manga he's
kind of using 100% at the moment so he's
loved
is that now it feels to use 100% we can
see what that like level of power is we
can see that already now in the manga
for the manga readers if you have a
anime only boom all that they're using
to let him use it without hurt yeah yeah
yeah so he's using that already we can
see that and it's not as strong as all
Mike it's stronger but it's not a lie
okay after once he can actually use that
level he then has to train at that level
in it to improve it so he can use it
better than whatever saw yeah yeah so
before we get into some hypothetical
death battles that we would want to see
and whether this whole concept is even a
possible anything else you guys want to
say about Bleach vs naruto ichigo vs
naruto in this case and whether you
prefer one or the other in general as an
anime slash manga I prefer Naruto I
would say I prefer none go Natsu yeah
okay well I'm not asking you fairytale
boy I'm not asking my answer is none I
prefer Naruto because bleach only had
one good arc and the entire series was
running on the soul society arc and if
not for that Bleach would be total crap
but they had a basis on that arc they
had no protagonist that had any
proactive goals it was just which you
know girl got captured this season -
lets go save Rukia or let's go save
orihime or let's go save this old
society who's captured by the Quincy's
he's a completely reactive protagonist
with no Flair really and it was all
riding on that soul Society art that
worked and then they tried to recreate
it eight times with you know basically
oh now we're fighting these bad guys
with those powers but it's the same
exact story yeah super eyepatch wolf in
his video the fall of leech made really
good arguments in this type of way
saying how you know now bleach started
off really well they had a good mold and
then they did it they were too afraid of
breaking that mold
trying to kind of relive it in different
settings with different powers well yeah
that's accurate yeah whereas Naruto was
good really until the end of the
invasion of Payne arc or until the five
Kage summit arc that was all pretty good
and then it just war arc was just hell
drawn-out hell with no you know sense
behind the crazy power boosts that
everyone seemed to be getting Oh Naruto
now has an ability to give every ninja
in the ninja alliance by the way that's
40,000 ninja to give all of those ninja
nine tails power now an infinite chakra
against all the revived characters from
all the previous episodes that they
finally beat you know there was quite
that has pulled thing happening well if
it went on for longer than he would have
been giving them the a low-low night
their Night Elves power - like it would
have been crazy that was a horrible joke
thank you I'm here all day anyway
anyways what what was I gonna say some
people were saying here about 400 sensei
and other characters yeah korosensei is
a very interesting character in terms of
power and stuff I would love to see him
fight some characters but soul your
thoughts in terms of bleach versus
Naruto
well like as series again series or who
do you think would win well yeah you can
do some manga well I think well
considering how both the mangas and I
would say that nooooo was more complete
in how it was done definitely um but I
don't know I mean if we're looking at
like powers and stuff and abilities
there was some pretty Opie characters on
both sides obviously Kaguya on a new
side and you had your watch or you ha
but he won on a bleep side and your side
Aizen actually because I sent Aizen was
pretty
can I just mention one thing about Aizen
once around the subject like while tied
to a chair the guy was still Opie
he was bounded at the blindfold thing on
his arms are tied you strapped to a
chair yet he was still like give enough
like hey why are you pressure or like a
key pressure if you're more familiar
with that term that was scaring people
Wow bounded which is supposed to
suppress he's like key we're soon level
you seem to maybe be overlooking he had
a sheik I do you remember what his
shikai can do she's chic I the Sheik I
was whoever looked at his sword you can
see many played essences yeah you'd
manipulate their sometimes you like
their senses that was gingy he can
completely control them mind control oh
no no you know it was perfect perfect
gnosis hypnosis doesn't yeah it's not
controlling them it's just is that she
guy for his fight against Ichigo
honestly if he would have said okay
instead of going into crazy ultra mode
I'm just gonna show you the stupid sword
and I've had for the last thousand years
yeah no no but that's the whole thing
with Aizen he defeated himself he
created Ichigo
to beat himself yeah I love that I have
made the ultimate plan to make you as
strong as possible to test my power and
defects him and I said yeah that's
that's basically that's basically what I
was yeah I mean it's very bad writing I
must say bleach is a series is Ichigo
never had no goal didn't I mention it
yeah no but I'm saying now that was the
problem with Beach as a series so every
time it was just like you know Winston
repeat with the arcs rinse repeat
there were great characters like he's
gay and kampachi we're both badasses and
I love them but no no no I don't know I
don't I don't I don't like Kempe
kampachi too much I liked
was it yo-yo yeah cheer oh yeah oh yeah
he's low lieutenant the time to be
engines boiler yeah I mean yeah that was
weird
I did I did like I was upsetting
hitsugaya he was good and um okay ice
guy de Rohan
you look like Gohan hmm oh I know I'm
what's the name of that the captain with
the cool robe with the pink and the
flowers oh my god yeah that's fun I like
that guy please
Jen's whoo yeah yeah yeah yeah him and
now Jesus Christ yeah yeah don't yeah
those characters were okay
like how laid-back he wasn't it yeah and
when he had his friend that was always
sick even though he had the God hand
inside him oh you're sick and you have
God having you at the same time that's
that's big
I mean if you have the right hand of God
inside you wouldn't you think
or was it no I think the left hand you
had the left hand of God inside him you
think that okay you've got the left hand
of God inside you doesn't that make you
like divine or something shouldn't you
be like really powerful or some now
there's a bear in the Cayenne awesome
now you know people need to need to
bring you tea and medicine and you never
actually really have a fight for out the
series yeah I mean yeah and I ride it's
good characters too I mean I liked
Itachi was beast
I liked pain and garen Lee go really
definitely shame it's a shame that
certain characters got left oh like Lee
wasted shinno and Tenten Jesus Chris
well she no intent and who liked them
let's be honest no but I mean come on
right you left those characters
disappeared like you didn't see them
until right at the end for they were
gonna take the mick and have a 10-10
seal Medora in the bottom right because
she found the parts yet she ready
fun in it
a foot damage she can become the hero
this of the series like she's been like
sidelines for so long that she has to do
something epic so they're gonna bring
her back and make her take out the last
villain yeah I mean but ya know that
that didn't happen that happens I feel
like literally no one but me here is
actually looking at the comments but
soul madness is answering some of your
illness related oh yeah with the
coughing and stuff so that yeah
sarcastic pun was saying something's off
[Music]
yeah no no but ya know see what
sarcastic pander is saying about Ichigo
like even wanting to know the truth from
once revenge and about his mother and
everything that didn't come till later
that didn't come till later until like
he got told oh yeah I know the truth
about your mom yeah I mean that was
never his goal from day one
his goal from day one was oh I need to
protect my family because he family was
getting touched and then he got the
power he protects his family after that
he was like okay I'm done but in wookie
was like no wait I ain't got my power
back you have to take over my role so
now he's forced to do this job and then
Rukia save her right yeah yeah exactly
exactly yeah I mean everything is as you
say reactionary yeah I mean from that
point and even wanting to know about his
mom and the truth about his past and all
that stuff he's still reactionary
because it was Aizen told him oh yeah I
know you truth about you I mean then
he's like okay right it's all on and on
what's the truth what's the truth what's
going on yeah I mean not he find out
until after aizen's been defeated so
it's funny also cuz I make so much fun
of the Naruto war arc and how the final
are Canary toe is like pretty mad
but the final arc in Bleach holy crap
that takes the cake for meth no yeah no
yeah they all got the final arc of
bleach was awesome it was that when I
was this bad Moose's baddest fairytale
as bad is very
like no get this fine no seriously you
get the final fight and you like okay
awesome
next chapter final chapter you that okay
awesome next thing you know you see
everyone gathered Lucy's selling some
kind of which one and then everyone's
that okay yeah we're going oh let's go
on an adventure you know which one was
it Solan are you saying one looking
about I'm talking about the manga you
don't know what it is week on
unfortunately because you're in very
Aleman
the end that would be natural ending
which is all in the manga yeah it just
it just came out of nowhere it was like
they were fight in two forms of this
villain yeah there's like these two
forms that are fighting okay they win
the fight and in the next chapter it's
just so many years later Lucy's got this
book she's getting an award for the book
you're spoiling on we've got the
confirmation on to Paris and me new
parents you pieces enough you think
you're gonna get a confirmation on Natsu
and you don't and then they just go off
on an adventure and that's it that's how
I am
recount isn't really a spoiler that he
told you they won the battle yeah I mean
come on
right no warrants name one battle they
lost by the way I saw in the chest
battle discussions of orihime versus
Sakura useless character nice
Gilgamesh's give you a donation he wants
to talk about fate to bubble yeah yoga
mesh gave $2 thank you bro but he wants
to talk about fate with brother soul or
body sucks fate sucks
there we go face brother topic but we
could talk about it in the after party
in the discord server by the way I'll
keep so quickly now let's get some ideas
for our epic death battles for the
future in the chat and also you guys
here I challenge you to come up with
some ones that are interesting such as
such as korosensei versus
verses are you waiting for us or are you
gonna tell telling us
I want to korosensei with someone but I
don't know whose think I'll try to work
out someone for korosensei yeah Kuro
sensei wait wait who is poor senses
masturbation classrooms I think I know
who I'm gonna call
okay okay who against our sensei who's
fast I don't know I'm ready to say mine
how about korosensei death battle with
like actually to the death with the
characters or Yuri oh nice I would be
really happy to see that quite frankly I
would I would I would pay good money to
see that
Oh bolt face wants to see Ines old ghoul
gown versus korosensei Ames would
probably win just before if I would um
oh no I'd have your Giro hanmer from
Bucky the grappler versus I feel like
you're just abusing your manga power
right now yeah from back into grappler
again I know a shitty carrot tipo the
first the first music Joseph Joestar
yeah that [ __ ] him I guarantee
you hungry goodbye I guarantee you her
nude muddy I have a great fight though
what about Maryland versus Frieza oh the
first one narrow him from Hunter has a
Honda Honda yeah is the guy kind of look
like um he looks a little like Frieza so
I fully realize so okay so chat fine
till him versus solid green and nobody
fights out I don't crap yeah I would
choose kitty tall versus Issei Hyodo
wait wait but if you do know him is that
like with wings or without Marilyn
Aaron doesn't have wings
no wings you know you never had the
wings nope
someone flew him around okay okay
and Kirito in case
Kirito only exists online he's actually
a loser 14 year old kid who is addicted
to video games and sits in his room all
day I don't care come on come on
illusion is not 14 he's laughing and
he's not a loser okay
Kirito gets the pull oh all the girls
okay he gets them all okay Jonathan
Essex wants to see no face from spirited
away versus Freeza that would be
interesting Robbie wants to see Android
18 versus the Android in one punch which
I'm guessing he means generals but no
contreras hello a dragon destroy him is
Dragonball also just once we were
mentioning one punch man
Saitama would beat everyone just because
his power is he wins in one punch
he beats a broad is it yes it that his
powers that he wins in one punch or that
he's been able to win in one punch so
far against everyone he faced but
there's a limit he's a comedy character
and therefore there's no limit well if
it's literally no limit than yes I guess
but well if you want a character with no
limit just look a Medeco karoku me
that's it from dekabox for medaka box
she has no limit as you can literally
copy anyone's ability anyone's ability a
little girl what about a key she's not
she's not like little little like she's
like I don't know 16 17 wha ya know what
I would like
Gilgamesh vs. Amir Fritz why would you
want to see that Amir Prince is
don't ask cuz you don't want to know
yeah she would lose her ass too yeah
yeah yeah that's all cannot cut food
dimensions and I can erase anything from
existence yeah a level above becoming a
Titan there's a level B out in the
garden it's just it's ridiculous
yeah I guess it also depends how you
look at fade because there's different
installments of fate where they have
different powers
well there's canon and canon fate makes
they also they also have different
statuses like some like they can be
berserker they can be saved but there
can be Lancer
yeah I mean so it's really funny faith
but it's all about the sevens for fate
that's that's how fate works in it yeah
it's interesting because it's hard to
say how powerful Gilgamesh would have
been as a human before he became a hero
right yeah yeah well then what does that
that's the thing though I mean that's
the thing that gets me would fate that
really kind of bugs me cuz I mean
they're supposed to be like heroic
spirits enter why all the servants in it
that heroic spirits yeah serious Wally
yeah Jack the Ripper what was heroic
about Jack the Ripper exactly that's
because you're looking at an English
translation the Japanese is the japanese
term was would actually really be
directly translated as people of legend
so legendary spirits legendary spirits
as opposed to heroic spirits yeah cuz I
was gonna say like Gilgamesh is all he's
too much of a dick to be a hero like the
personality he's got yes this it's not
about heroes it's about yeah to be the
king of Heroes that personality has to
go I'm sorry this you know yeah so I
think that is a good point
Knox that you bring up that nice little
fact that if it's legendary that it
doesn't matter as long as they had
notoriety right yeah impact doesn't
matter if it's good or bad I
Yukie would beat Goku he would just
challenge him to duel and seal him in
the shadow around the end you you Yugi
moto from you you know that Goku would
just go shadow super sand and break out
of it
well you don't know the pupcake let's be
honest here do you know what the Shadow
Realm is utter because Goku will gold
shadow super saiyan whatever that is
well I will explain to you exactly what
it is um in the Japanese version there
was no Shadow Realm in all of yugioh the
character would die but in the for kids
version they're like oh he can't they
can't can't kill them so they came up
with this whole Shadow Realm BS so that
there wouldn't be dead I see well the
point is whatever it is Goku could break
out of it cuz Goku always finds a way to
do anything and even if he even if he
goes and beats a super powerful guy and
then he loses to a much weaker guy he
still wins somehow
yeah Goku is pretty cool like that yes
by the way guys like I said we'll do
after partying voice shot in Disco but
before we go I got a package that I'm
gonna open right now
I just got it before we went online okay
check this out
I haven't even seen it obviously what
whoa whoa we're not even gonna get like
a little hint of what it's supposed to
be what what's this guy's which is body
pillow what is actually getting t-shirts
nice comment and I put Anna Mack please
don't wear them please do not wear that
in public
I will definitely wear this in public
you forgive any Disney designs that I
came up with cuz we're gonna be selling
anime merch anime uproar we haven't
launched the store official yet although
there's a secret link in the description
if you want to check it out it is why
but we just don't promote it in yet but
these are some of the designs that I
came up with and my friend helped me
create
you're seeing them right now for the
first time along with me well I saw it
already so well not just then let
everyone else enjoy a great calls me
senpai
well anime well regardless how does this
you happy I'm currently working on a
video why fairytales not bad I've got
I've got another idea for a vs. battle
it's like a versus battle of the like
the two biggest like anime or manga
[ __ ]
and that would be Gilgamesh versus
Excalibur from Soul Eater Excalibur is
awesomeness okay though understand the
true power of Excalibur you don't
understand life although black star
versus Astro would be a great fight
because whoever dies laughing they're
both just is amazing
I was just watching you they watch that
fight on mute though yeah both kill each
other soul madness said that I have
ascended to the next step of we've done
it is it is true hmm but this is the
next shirt guys this is the next shirt
you've heard of eat sleep anime repeats
well this is this is the next level this
is the next level and Amanda Manning me
yeah there's no eat sleep better or pee
guys this is eat sleep and then full
animates you go full and if a Gilgamesh
asked who printed this actually it's T
public so basically you create designs
you upload them and they ship them for
you they print them and actually the
quality looks point about I'm seeing it
for the first time but very cool and the
last one so far that we have is d equal
Isaac anime out Pro shirt first line of
ten of and people kept asking how can we
get I'm like we don't know man I don't
know how to print I'm I don't know how
to send them now you can actually order
them but we haven't promoted to store
yet but I didn't leave a secret they can
description if you want to check it out
well yeah I'm liking it man this is this
quality what we've done before but
anywho 3.com are you here he's not here
yeah I'm here
are you ordering dot hentai shirt yeah
that's what he's doing he's ordered will
you wear it to Universal mean you yeah
he I go to university and wear that
completely normal individual that's not
weird in any way no way if I were to say
I would get my ass whooped I'll visit
his University and I'll take a snapshot
of Rico in the shirt yeah please don't
you can put that with the other one that
we have just for you I might if a damag
gives me a special if Ana mine gives me
a special sale and I will get definitely
get it and I'll wear it
yeah yeah look I'll give you a special
sale it comes with my respect awesome
love that the cartoon man just said my
favorite death battle idea so far spike
from Cowboy Bebop vs Mugen from samurai
champloo I would love to see that I love
both of those characters Mugen would
kill him though it's like interesting
yeah I mean I dare there are cool
characters they're really cool
characters but I think Mugen will kill a
man
Mugen is yeah yeah he's a bit of a
roughneck come on yeah like it's
interesting because spike also knows
martial arts yeah and yes guns but Mugen
is just an insane completely crazy I
love those guys yeah him engine him and
Jenna great in summer champloo
yeah I'm Anna Mac you ever watched try
gun yep so hit wolfwood and vash are a
great team as well Blair with Bosch is a
bit too much like monkey from Junie
we talked about that before no he's not
doesn't want to kill anyone
well I still like a slide from that
they're completely different because
vash is an amazing character and monkeys
terrible
so about Vash versus spiked them Vash
has an arm cannon thing they can like
destroy a planet yeah the thing is Vash
would win in a fight but he wouldn't
kill him because he doesn't kill anyone
yeah and that might give then spike the
chance to come back again
except he could blow up a planet with
one shot yeah but he don't want to but
he would you see you see how that works
you don't want to kill him yeah he would
never destroy an entire planet so he
would imitate him Vash is one of those
guys that you like have to respect
because even though that he has that
whole kind of armor I'm a good guy thing
too much he's still so funny and an
interesting character they used to like
them it's not like oh man this guy just
pisses me off yeah he's pretty badass
yeah oh yeah these shirts guys I'm
pretty I'm pretty impressed can't wait
to try this [ __ ] on all right how's this
Alucard or ein duel gown i Lucado you do
thanks
no I don't know I feel God would win
that you know I mean I know I like my
coal moves and there's crazy he's crazy
in he's like world but so is Alucard
like you see now crazy Alucard is in his
world
yes so i mean yeah i don't know i I
don't know I would take I would choose
like alucard just for the simple fact of
he's more like he feels more attacking
deny yummy Ines feels like he more like
defensively sees if he can tank first
and then reacts to it whereas Alucard he
kind of like can't
but then sneekly gets he's attack in
there you know he like sets it up in it
so after he's packed he's like oh yeah
okay boom got you well if you think
about it
if you think about it you look awesome
look it's an alibi basically the same
character as Ines like they're very
similar yeah they are quite similar
because they they tank first but like
I'm saying the difference is like ions
were like tank and then he'll basically
then take his turn and go like okay this
is my attack
whereas Alucard feels like he tanks but
sets up in the same in the same hand in
it so he's ducks
knocks before you do that everyone let
me know in the chat if you would
actually wear this shirt I'm liking it
right you keep posing and I'll ask my
question who would win okay good
not sue or Sinbad not sue or Simba Jesus
is that like big body thing in it you
know the big weird body thing
my money's on Sinbad he's too bad as to
ever lose okay I don't know I don't know
cuz I mean if you look at like what nuts
you can do in his universe you put you
by those two like when I'm taking them
but we gotta like a certain time limit
that we we're putting putting the cap on
or we just going with what we know so
far well what do you mean what we know
so far both manga ended well always
Mikey ended
yeah Maggie's done oh sure no [ __ ] so we
just realized monkeys a lot of series
that don't know well since that drop
will get tied to this became better show
us the last bogie I've ever watched was
Sinbad no bulk and that was the last one
I think you mean that was the latest one
yeah the latest one that yeah this
really goes whatever mommy but I still
have to watch Sinbad well I like the
whole Maggie
franchise it's one of my favorite to be
honest it's cool
it's interesting yeah oh yeah I like
meant a lot of miss such a perm and just
loves tits
yeah mayor in the child and he's like 11
or something to make it better
mayor's mentioned a certain iconic
character of me in him called Strauss
Aki Bauer from vampire juju Kai or also
known as a record of a fallen vampire
which I've recommended to you on a Mac
to read no I think I think I think an
interesting verse as much would be him
versus Eva what's his name Lelouch oh no
make it a freeway strategy about Strauss
versus Lelouch versus Itachi there you
go yeah three ways that's that's an even
more complicated thing it's like who
gets who but it's interesting
mmm all right guys I think we can wrap
it up now and go into the after party on
the voice chat in the our discord server
after this thank you so much for tuning
in fun conversation recon thank you for
coming NOx and soul maka
pleasure guys Fletcher Nukem anything
you guys want to say before we go and by
the way link to all their channels are
in the description they're all youtubers
now including soul maka so all their
links are in the description anything
you guys want to say before we go I'm a
sexy beast I would make my own shirt I
would say keep calm and watch harem
what about very original very original
totally not based on anything but people
that people in the Chad did say that I
looked sexier with that shirt because
now I'm making people think I'm hentai
and they're associating those positive
memories with me so you know it works it
works I like it alright guys thank you
for joining me everyone in the Chad you
guys lovely people on the panel
including recon and yeah let's just head
over to the voice chat and chill over
there in discord man thank you for
joining us next week we're back to say
our outro anime who knows what panel
we're back with don't know true
who knows what panel we're back with
next week who knows the topic it's all
it's all crazy but yeah until next time
see ya space